متحف عبد الله الشريف من اهم معالم هرر
وخلال جولتنا زرنا المتحف الخاص للسيد عبد
الله الذي حول بيته لتحفه فنيه جمع فيها
العديد من المخطوطات العربيه القديمه
وعملات معدنيه ومقتنيات تراثيه تحط رحالها
في الماضي
شريف
هذا هو متحف شريف الخاص وانا من قمت
بتاسيسه وقمت بجمع العديد من المقتنيات
الاثريه وفي هذا المتحف يوجد العديد من
المخطوطات يعود تاريخها الى 1300 عام وما
ترونه هنا هو مجرد عينات لما يوجد لدينا
من المخطوطات ودعوني اخذكم الى غرفه
التخزين السريه لديه والتي يوجد فيها
العديد من المخطوطات القيمه والنادره ستور
هنا توجد المجموعه الرئيسيه من المخطوطات
التي نحتفظ بها في هذا المتحف وتوجد هنا
كتب في مختلف المجالات العلميه مثل علوم
القران والحديث وعلوم النحو بالاضافه الى
الطب والرياضيات وغيرها وما نقوم به ليس
تجميع المخطوطات فحسب بل نقوم بصيانتها
واعاده عمل الغطاء للكتب من الجلد